[Musique]
Je suis d'accord photo la Brigid Mahoney ajouter un
module st laisser reposer une camote tapoté sur
plus dédaigneux demander à un expert en meurtre
commune pase de so steeleville IL photo
accompagner sa fille Adama bodacious
montant Kayla création dos Pascal per
voir en robe en public ou  film ou sacs
table profond certains sont un formidable
formidable pour mala Sinha veto également le
définitif et sont efficaces pour
antitoxine ou moustique harmonica dommages
avec le plan de Cervantes vos
ratios de crédit développer remarque regarde maman Suzie
amor SE hace la Marck
améliorer père LaFrance no Elvis
la contrainte était mo dit mark he avek
Sewell attirance pour la négligence soins
politique criminelle intrusion restreindre
difficile important le faux prêtre
sport est un conseil le vétérinaire ne restreint pas l'
élingue un multi-moniteur physique
concernant Sarkozy les dames sont poly le
barrage de rupture avec Raymond rupture
macaroni partitions de  ivali risotto sur
scène je suis un homme regarde Eclair l manuel
kill la vie
c'est une autre expression design mais on
veut changer en France il y a un
logiciel quiz positif surtout si
tu vas dans d'autres pays en Asie pour
venir chez nous avec des musulmans tu as
pour faire attention bien sûr, il faut
s'adapter aux gens, par exemple
Michelle Obama portait
des vêtements qui ressemblaient à une adaptation à la
culture qu'il a vue et je pense qu'elle a
un peu résisté à ça donc elle veut
montrer son style et c'est tout  le
look militaire est toujours bon puisque vous vous
sentez protégé mais vous ne devez pas seulement
être protégé mais vous devez montrer
quelque chose aux autres pour sortir de
votre rôle peut-être qu'elle veut
vous protéger exactement elle veut
vous protéger de l'opinion publique  bien sûr
oui - comme toute famille Adam, elle souffre
de l'opinion publique, bien sûr, vous pensez
qu'elle en souffre parce que beaucoup de
gens écrivent des choses sur eux qu'ils
ne connaissent pas et il y a beaucoup de rumeurs et
beaucoup de mauvaises choses et donc elle prend l'
uniforme  doit être plus forte, elle est un peu
à l'écoute pour vous rencontrer, vous savez, très
soignée, très gentille, très correcte, tout est parfait,
exactement sous contrôle et tout est
parfait et tout est entre nos
mains, mais en tant que femme française, vous devriez
jouer un peu plus avec ce rôle de femme en
Allemagne.  dépensé plus d'argent en mode qu'en
France personne n'y croit mais c'est
comme si les françaises savaient mieux mélanger
comment jouer avec et aller dans une
boutique quelque part sur Vidya tabouli et
acheter un pantalon pour 60 ans
qui n'est pas du pain alors et elle  je devrais mélanger
davantage, mon modèle pour chaque
femme française est Estella Hassan qui le sait le
mieux, alors vous me conseilleriez ceci -
ouais, allez déjeuner avec Eunice